dude read performance reviews you're not  alone only 14% of employees strongly  agree that reviews inspire them to  improve in fact 57% of workers  understand the need to acquire new  skills in order to accelerate career  growth that's why more businesses today  are using skill development training as  a way to measure and reward employees  certification training gives you more  than skills it gives you the credibility  and confidence you need to advance your  career prove that your skills align with  business goals future proof your value  even as jobs change sew up skill and  artificial intelligence and machine  learning data science cloud computing  DevOps  Big Data project management digital  marketing cybersecurity blockchain IT  service and architecture agile and scrum  and gain a competitive edge  [Music]